[موسيقى]
صدى الأذان في
القدس يتردد في
الشوارع المزدحمة عادة الآن شبه فارغة
يقول والي إنه يأتي إلى متجره فقط لتغيير
المشهد لأنه لا أحد
يشتري أي شيء، كما يقول الفلسطينيون الذين
يخبروننا أنهم خائفون من الإسرائيليين
الشرطة التي تعيش أساسًا في ظل حظر التجول
تعرف أن
الأطفال الصغار هم الأشخاص الوحيدون الذين
رأيناهم بأعداد ملحوظة
لأن الشباب يخافون من أننا ذهبنا
للتحدث معهم في القدس الشرقية وكانوا
خائفين للغاية من التحدث أمام الكاميرا،
أخبرنا محمد الله يسعدكم
طريقة  يقول أنا آسف لا أستطيع التحدث إذا
فعلت ذلك ويضيف سأذهب إلى السجن
وأظهر لنا أحدهم لماذا يعتقدون أن
هذا فيديو تيك توك على هاتفه
وقد انتشر بين الشباب الفلسطيني كما
يقول  تخطط إسرائيل لإصدار قانون جديد
لسحب الجنسية أو الهوية الوطنية
لأي شخص يدعم الإرهاب،
وصحيح أن مسؤولي الحكومة الإسرائيلية
يقترحون مثل هذا القانون، وبالنسبة لهؤلاء الشباب
فهذا يعني أنه يمكن اعتقالهم بسبب
أي شيء يقولون لنا إنهم سيذهبون إلى السجن.
إذا كان لديهم آية قرآنية على
الشاشة الرئيسية لهواتفهم أو إذا نشروا
صورة لفلسطيني ميت، بحثنا في
القانون الإسرائيلي الحالي، فهو يقرأ
جزئيًا أي شخص يرتكب عملاً من أعمال
التماهي مع منظمة إرهابية،
بما في ذلك من خلال نشر الثناء
والدعم أو التقارب.  التلويح بعلم
يظهر أو يروج لرمز أو يظهر
عزفًا أو يروج لشعار أو نشيد وطني،
الحكم هو السجن لمدة ثلاث سنوات
في الواقع منذ بدء الحرب. لقد
اعتقلت إسرائيل بالفعل عدة مئات من الشباب
الفلسطينيين معطيين
تفسيرًا بسيطًا بأنهم
ينتمون إلى
حماس والخوف
منتشر كان شاب اسمه فيصل
يخاف من الاعتقال، أخبرنا أنه تم
إطلاق سراحه مؤخرًا بعد 18 شهرًا من
السجن بعد أن قال إنه تم اعتقاله في
مظاهرة بالقرب من مسجد الأقصى في القدس،
أخبرتنا مجموعة من الشباب أنهم'  لقد تعرضنا
للضرب على يد الشرطة على طول هذا الجدار في
الجزء السفلي من شارعهم، لكن الرجال
كانوا مضيافين لنا، وأعطانا البعض الماء
ورفضوا أخذ المال على الرغم من أنهم
يقولون إنه لا يوجد عمل ولا مال
ولا مصدر رزق لهم
الآن مقابل كل شيء